I can't believe I even have to do this
but it's increasingly unclear to me that
Donald Trump can comfortably read the
written English language I mean like
English written on pages I genuinely
think after reviewing a bunch of videos
and comments and evidence yesterday that
Donald Trump may barely be able to read
let's start with some journalists who
have interviewed Donald Trump who have
come to the conclusion that certainly
Donald Trump doesn't read we'll start
there there was one point when I asked
him how he was preparing to possibly be
President and are you reading the great
presidential biographies for example and
he paused for an unusually long time his
voice became almost tender and he said
you know I've never read a biography but
I've always wanted to you ask him and
he's because he's leaving the interview
and going to bed him what are you
reading what was that what did you say
he kind of had that look oh yeah you got
me and then he tried to answer and he
said he's reading this this book by that
Ed Klein wrote a hatchet job on Hillary
Clinton of which I'm sure he's not
reading then there was a book about
Nixon which he couldn't remember exactly
right so Trump has said many times on
the campaign trail that one of the main
reasons he'd be a good president was
because of the stuff that he wrote about
his life in art of the deal but of
course we know he didn't actually write
it and one of the most notable things to
come from an interview with the guy who
actually wrote art of the deal Tony
Schwartz is that he realized that not
only did Trump have essentially no
attention span whatsoever which connects
to his concerning level of TV watching
that we've heard about over the last
week or so but also that he would be
shocked to learn that Trump had read a
single book cover-to-cover
in his entire adult life again this is a
quote from an interview with Tony Tony
Schwartz where he said that's why he so
prefers TV as his first news source
information comes in easily digestible
sound bites I seriously doubt that Trump
has ever read a book straight through in
his adult life he also said that during
the entire 18 months that he was writing
the book with Trump and observing Trump
he never once even saw a book on Donald
Trump's desk or anywhere on his off in
his office or in his apartment so fine
Donald Trump doesn't read but can he
read is really the question let's now
put this together would that report from
last week from Axios calm about the
total disarray that the Trump
administration is in and one of the main
disturbing aspects of the early days of
the Trump administration according to
insiders at the Trump White House is
that Donald Trump seems fixated fixated
on watching TV and cannot focus on nor
read any of the reports or briefings or
white papers or anything his advisers
have even said he doesn't even really
surf the web or use a computer he'll
scroll through Twitter on his phone and
dictate tweets to people in the other
room that's yet another layer to this
thing that Donald Trump may not only
have trouble reading but also have
trouble writing as we've talked about
before and Trump has even tweeted about
this himself I dictate my tweet to my
executive assistant and she posts them
quote time is money source the art of
the deal of course the phrase time is
money didn't even come from the art of
the deal and again this further
continues to call into question both
Donald Trump's reading and writing
skills his advisers have now also said
Trump avoids reading any report or
briefing that he finds to be too lengthy
and he will often just glance at the
first page without even making it
evident whether he understands what's on
the page it continues listen to this
strange conversation that Mark Fisher
had with Donald Trump so I pressed a
little harder and I said well how are
you preparing how will you make
decisions as president and he said well
I'm not going to be reading any big
reports or anything like that and he
told me the story of how a guy from Wall
Street came to him wanted him to make a
deal in China and said there was an
innovative kind of financing that he
wanted Trump to consider and so Trump
said I don't know anything about that
you guys had no problem we've done some
research I have a report I'll send it to
you today and
some said don't send me any blanking
reports and said because I won't read
them and here is Trump telling Chuck
Todd that he gets his foreign policy
advice from TV odd place for a
presidential candidate to be getting
foreign policy advice who do you talk to
for military advice right now well I
watch your shows I mean I really see a
lot of great you know when you watch
your show and all of the other shows and
you have the generals and you have
certain people so that circumstantial
Trump doesn't read but is he avoiding
reading because he doesn't like it or
because he has trouble reading and here
is where it all explodes I recently saw
this interview I'm about to play for you
on the Opie with Jim Norton radio show
with Saturday Night Live's Pete Davidson
and Pete Davidson described that when
Trump was a guest hosting Saturday Night
Live he genuinely seemed unable to read
the script take a look at this okay so
he's like he doesn't really know how to
read for real yeah so during like the
table read he like before like we were
gonna leave eat before he had to read
each line and he's the host so he's at
everything yeah he would go I'm not
going to say this so they would say it
the way I want to say is it okay he said
Oh Caitlyn is everything literally like
what and then this is my favorite part
is there was a sketch that we wrote
where he's at Disneyland with his
daughter and the line is uh alright
let's get out of here turkey legs like
let's like go get to like every heat of
an otter read so he went all right let's
get out of here turkey leg he called his
daughter turkey legs and then he looked
at like he doesn't get it like he thinks
if everybody's laughing with him but
we're all laugh I got it so this would
explain why it's such a disaster every
time Trump you tries to use a
teleprompter not because he's unfamiliar
with prompters but because he's not a
very good reader let's take a look at
just one of these awkward teleprompter
debacles everything that is broken today
can be fixed and every failure can be
turned
into a truly great success just look at
the way I just meld it into the
teleprompter yeah so now here's where it
gets completely nuts oh I took a look at
some specific portions of a deposition
that Trump gave in June of last year and
there is some really really clear
attempts here to avoid having to read
out loud his lawyer clearly doesn't want
Trump to do any reading out were out
loud and here is the first clip where
Trump says I don't read leases let's
start with that did you review the lease
at all before you signed it no how many
leases like this have you reviewed in
your career signed or reviewed reviewed
not too many I signed one hundred right
so he's never really reviewed a lease
and then he's asked to read a portion
and his lawyer really doesn't like it
yeah you did not review this section or
related monetary damages this is the
remedies I did not know okay would you
be able to read this section and tell us
what your understanding of it is
objection mr. Trump isn't a lawyer I
mean do you want me to read it
seven long it is long very long edit
long so then it looks like maybe Trump
is actually going to read his lawyer
seeming increasingly nervous and it gets
really weird
I would I would like you to read just
the monetary damages section starting at
the number one in the middle of the page
just there the rest of that and to the
end of that it saw it continues on the
next page and tell me what you think
reading that you as the landlord are
entitled to get from the tenant in the
event of a tenant breach in the way of
damages in one of my classes I am like
this is that because I didn't bring my
glasses justice actual writing alright
well the witness can't actually
physically freed the language I mean
impoverished Mulroney now I can I can
make it out to want me to try well we
can have you know what we can do we can
have a bigger copy made of these pages
let me try largest I have to place on
the record a hearty objection
awkward
barry off
insanely awkward so long pause looking
at the page looking confused he doesn't
have his glasses with him have we ever
seen Trump wearing glasses when signing
executive orders have we ever seen Trump
wearing glasses at those countless
rallies where he goes up onstage with
polling data to read to people no here's
an example again never any glasses
alright so South Carolina just came out
and that's thirty two for Trump eighteen
per second eleven for third great
Florida leading by a lot thirty-one 1913
and then all down in the dumps so again
he's able to read numbers off of a page
didn't seem to have a problem there
without his glasses we've never seen him
wear glasses but all of a sudden at the
deposition he doesn't have his glasses
and then his lawyer objects again as you
heard
lastly Trump stares at it for a while
and then again instead of reading it he
sort of weirdly paraphrases what he
thinks it says yeah it's the old damages
that the landward may sustain including
all legal fees and everything else
involved looks like everything in the
kitchen sink to me and you have number
two
yeah
go on
the value the positive difference with
the aggregate amount of the Dacians and
the additional rent the guy can barely
read that I am convinced he can barely
read and even on an inauguration day I
didn't think much of this Trump seemed
confused about which orders he was
signing and where to sign but it's all
part of this he kept having to be told
what he was signing and now it all comes
together the guy barely can comprehend
what's on pieces of paper so we may have
a trump president we may have a
president in Trump here who isn't
speaking at a fourth-grade level because
it's some genius way to appeal to people
it's because he's reading at a fourth
grade level and that's the highest level
he's able to speak at I mean I'm not
sure if we're you have enough here to
make a conclusion on his raw reading
ability now but the lack of intellectual
curiosity is what bothers me because you
can get books on tape you can have
advisors come in and tell you what the
policy proposals are there's ways around
this there are ways around it but this
is all incredibly disturbing and I'm
curious to see what the audience thinks
about it